[Music]
immunity has been on everyone's lips
since the pandemic began
now it's more pressing than ever as
infections rapidly rise in parts
immunity depends on antibodies proteins
in the bloodstream that fight pathogens
and viruses
[Music]
their production depends on the severity
of an infection
but immunity from covert may only last a
short period
the elderly show a significantly faster
reduction in antibodies than the young
there's also evidence that some people
don't develop immunity at all
[Music]
we're still waiting for the science to
see how long immunity lasts
in the meantime some places in the world
view it as a health
passport for tourists one little island
in south america will only let you in if
you can prove you've already had the
coronavirus
my trip to brazil's island paradise of
fernando j
neronia was completely stress free
actually i had to do a blood test first
i need these lab test results for my
trip to paradise
here it says antibodies igg 5.78
that's more than five times what i need
even though i've had covid19
i'm allowed to travel
i quickly packed my things so i can set
off the next morning
my cameraman juan pablo and i probably
became infected with the coronavirus
right at the start of the pandemic
when we were filming we were in manaus
where the healthcare system had
collapsed
this is the only flight this week that
takes off for the island
sitting next to me is carolina sampaio a
businesswoman
she's been there 50 times
[Music]
my life is starting again fernando
is the most beautiful place in the world
she may be right
[Music]
like everyone else on this flight
carolina has had the coronavirus
we must now stand in line and pay an
environmental fee
strict rules for entering paradise
the island has been virtually cut off
from the outside world since march due
to the pandemic
according to our guide aiton we're now
the first tourists in what authorities
say
is an absolutely coronavirus free part
of the earth
one big plus the beautiful beaches are
empty
before the island was declared a nature
preserve it was a notorious prison camp
and before that a base for warships
built on ancient volcanic rock
[Music]
when the pandemic started in march and
neuronia
was cut off from the rest of brazil a
curfew was also imposed
[Music]
only the fishermen were allowed to go
out
in order that no one starved islanders
felt a new sense of solidarity
the authorities gave us diesel fuel we
used it to go out and fish
in the end we gave away our entire catch
to the islanders for free
crisis management has been exemplary
thanks in part to random checks the
island has not had a single case of
coronavirus
even if more tourists come we probably
won't have a coronavirus outbreak
we've taken a lot of preventative
measures
such as allowing in visitors who have
already had coven 19
they have this picturesque coast almost
all to themselves
a privilege that at least somewhat
compensates for what they've been
through
[Music]
i survived to the coronavirus it wasn't
easy now it's time to make up for it
we have the island almost all to
ourselves i'll probably never again
experience a paradise like this
at moments like these the pandemic feels
far away
but just how immune are you if you've
had the coronavirus
deepta bhattacharya joins us now from
the university of arizona college of
medicine he's an associate professor in
immunobiology
what do your results on immunity show
our results show that for at least
people with mild infections the course
of the immune response seems
pretty much as we would expect for most
types of acute viral infections where
after you clear it
there's a certain period of immunity our
study followed out
antibodies and especially protective
antibodies out to the course of about
seven months
and our studies show as have many others
that those antibodies continue to be
produced for as long as we've been able
to look
is there any indication that it could be
more than months it could be years
yeah i mean so when i say seven months i
don't mean up to seven months i mean at
least seven months
um you know the pandemic hit our state
fairly late and so we just don't have
any participants who are infected any
earlier than seven months
but if you look just by parallels to the
first sars coronavirus which is the most
similar virus we've seen
um you know those antibodies and people
who saw the first sars chronovirus are
continuing to be produced now 17 years
after the fact
i don't know if this one will be quite
that long but you know i think a year to
two
it seems like a reasonable minimum
estimate
that sounds quite optimistic though
because other coronaviruses
have shown that immunity can drop off
after a year
yeah i mean i guess the question is
what's the best prior what's the best
analogy and so
you know genetically and in terms of the
nucleotide sequence of the virus it's
really most similar to the first stars
coronavirus so
i think maybe like the best way to hedge
your bets is say it's probably going to
be something in between
you know a year or so which is what the
common coronavirus is induced
and the 17 years that we feel from the
first stars coronavirus
you know ultimately we don't have a
crystal ball and so there's really no
way to take a shortcut here there's no
way to know
until we just start to follow it out um
people who get the virus badly though
have have shown that they have more
antibodies and they have them for longer
what's that tell us
well um yeah i mean there's a lot of
things that go wrong the people who end
up with severe disease in the early
stages of the immune response there's
a huge amount of inflammation and
uncoordinated signals the kinds of
things that we don't normally see
so there's something strange going on
presumably the levels of virus are
higher
the amount of antibodies produced are
also higher
and so you know it's going to come take
a little bit longer for those antibodies
to come down than people who have very
mild disease and make fewer
antibodies you know whether or not the
people with severe disease will actually
be immune for longer is that something i
think we still need to see because again
a lot of things
don't really work right in the severe
phase and so it could affect
some of the long-term antibody
production we just don't know
what's this all mean for a vaccine
because a vaccine provokes an antibody
response of course
yeah i mean i'm actually very optimistic
about the efficacy potential of the
vaccines that i've seen so far
so you know one of the things that we
have noticed is that
um you know you get this nice uh
stereotypical pattern of antibodies and
they settle in a pretty low level
and based on the epidemiology we've seen
so far i mean it seems to be protective
i'm sure you'll want to get to
re-infections in a little bit
but it seems like pretty low levels of
antibodies are still protective
the vaccine data we've seen so far i
mean all of the ones that at least are
being tested here in the u.s
all exceed the normal immune response to
a natural infection and so
if if the natural infection can induce
immunity i'm pretty optimistic that
these vaccines will as well
many things we still need to find out
how long will the vaccine immunity last
for all and what are the safety effects
all those things but
all of the early indications i've seen
so far make me very optimistic
university of arizona thank you very
much
thank you and to bring you up to date
here are the latest data from more than
200 countries and territories on coveted
infections
the numbers show new cases doubling in
39 nations
and increasing in another 94 countries
they've stayed at the same level in
eight countries
55 nations have seen their new positive
covet 19 cases declined
another nine are down by at least half
and six countries have reported no new
cases for four weeks in a row
here's the bar graph showing the
statistics of past weeks
the fight against the coronavirus will
be over when that whole chart turns blue
so it's going to take some time
now it's that part of the show where you
get to ask the questions to our science
correspondent derek williams
does improving ventilation make confined
spaces like
restaurants or bars safer to operate
because we now believe that aerosols
play a role in covet 19 transmission
at least in enclosed spaces adequate
ventilation
would appear to be a key aspect of
lowering risk
in public spaces like restaurants and
bars
but also schools but what's adequate
exactly well that's pretty hard to nail
down
but because we tend to spend longer
periods of time in those spaces than we
do for example somewhere
like a corner shop the general consensus
among virologists
and airflow experts can be boiled down
to
the more outside air you can pull in
the safer you can make those
environments
so instead of asking whether improving
ventilation can make
restaurants and bars safer it's more
accurate to talk about
what's called the air exchange rate
which describes the number of times
that the air is replaced in a room over
the course of an hour
i read a quote recently from one of the
experts on air flow who's advising the
german government on keeping schools
open
that really opened my eyes about the
complexity of this issue he said
it doesn't matter how effective air
exchange
strategies are if someone who is
infectious
is in a room the air can only really be
cleaned
if they leave it in other words
transmission risks
in spaces like bars and restaurants can
only
potentially be reduced by air
replacement systems and and even then
they have to be pretty high performance
to make much of a difference
but those risks rise again the moment
more customers come
and spend time in those spaces because
the chances rise that one of them
might be infected in shedding virus